[Music]
the what podcast which bands this year
that matter oh hi
friend
uh very quarter i'm brad steiner i'm not
barry he's barry
i'm brad
yeah how are you buddy hi brad i'm doing
great how are you doing i'm doing super
too uh i want to get right into this
because it's a very lengthy chat with a
human being who we adore and we have the
utmost respect for and not only that
it's
very insightful not only to see how the
festival world and the music experiences
are changing and evolving but also if
you are
a bonnaroo nerd festival nerd you're
going to get a lot of answers a big
chunk of
our chat today with jeff cuellar the
back half of it is all about
bonnaroo and his time there which was
considerable considerable for 20 some
odd years yeah not just bon rou
rail bird forecastle if anybody in the
industry knows anything about the growth
of festivals in uh america since
bonnaroo came on board in 2002 it's jeff
cuellar he's
he's been the face of it he's been the
guy behind the scenes
he's been as you point out brad and i
think you nailed it right on he is
he's the brand he is the voice of the
brand put it that way he's the guy that
when we had questions had the answer
and he's the guy that helped drive the
the train so to speak on uh
a lot of uh what has developed over the
years i tell you the people i like the
most in this industry are the ones that
make it look easy yeah everything he
does he makes look easy makes it great
because he's the coolest cat in the
world that's a great point um he just
makes everything look so effortless
almost to the point where i ask myself
what does he do for a living
uh is he this is this job because it
seems so
easy for him it just rolls off of his
tongue excellent communicator uh remind
me before we get into this explain his
job and what he's doing now
vis-a-vis what he was doing before with
bonnaroo he was very similar actually
when he was at bonnaroo he when we first
met him he was at ac entertainment and
then which was bought by lime nation his
job was essentially
vice president of partnerships and it
had a whole long string of things behind
it
uh he once told me he's kind of the guy
that when they have a new thing
and they can't figure out who should be
in charge it becomes jeff
uh so he's bp well over 20 years
everything became a new thing yeah he
was the guy that you know hey uh tv
stations want to quote go get jeff
hey what should we do with this vip
section
uh go ask jeff uh you know so he had he
literally had his hand in everything he
currently is
vice president of partnerships with
sixth man s-i-x-t-h-m-a-n
uh which is
and we talk about it the global leader
in festivals at sea but also sand and
land so he's shifted jobs so he's very
much doing the exact same thing it
sounds like
um just on a boat just on a boat just on
a boat on a boat and on on islands that
uh that the company owns yeah pretty
sweet spots yeah
but you know
when you were talking about how what a
cool guy is i mean one of the questions
we asked him is about that decision back
in september to cancel bonnaroo
and uh
i mean he gave he gave the right answer
i can only imagine
how gut-wrenching all of that was but
like you said
they handled it like professionals uh
made the right decision so
he's we've said it for whatever five
years now having him on as a guest that
first time i think is when we realized
this show
uh could be a little bit more than what
we originally thought because of people
like him that's right yeah i mean we we
we originally thought yeah that's
exactly right that conversation changed
the entire direction of this of this
entity and um there's one answer he
gives in particular about this
about this festival that we all love so
much that
really warms my heart uh it makes me
very very excited uh and you'll hear it
their chat with jeff coyle
who was just so wonderful with his time
i hope you enjoy it uh we will not be
back after the after the the interview
so enjoy that today and we'll be back
next week on the what podcast and you
know enjoy it's jeff cuellar
[Music]
you're gonna be living within an hour of
very quarter i know i will
i can ignore him from 90 minutes away
yeah let me
let me give you a hint i lived five
minutes from berry quarter i still never
saw him so
you're in for a treat my friend you're
in for a treat
nice
we're definitely being honest what part
are you what part of the country are you
in now i'm currently still in northern
california just outside the bay area so
you're leaving northern california for
atlanta
you say it's so uh
so spiritually like you know i'm not
looking making a good move here uh yes
yes i yes i i am i am uh and i will say
i the things there there are there are
less things i will miss
um
than than things i will not miss
sure biggest thing that's a big thing
let me just let's start with the obvious
question question have you ever been to
atlanta
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah i have never lived in atlanta yet i
have i've had good times in atlanta and
i got this close to producing a festival
in atlanta but um
we ended up pulling the plug due to um
a hurricane that came through if you
guys remember remember when tomorrow got
knocked out it was just outside of
atlanta uh we got the remnants of that
that destroyed our build for afropunk
when we were we were producing oh yeah
yeah yeah i do remember that
so i've had some fun in atlanta uh i
like i've seen the house that i
purchased um it seems it seems cool i'm
excited about the area
as someone who is preparing for a move
myself i
um i'm literally
do you know how fear the fear that lives
inside of me to sign a lease with an
apartment slash building that you've
never seen before i've done it twice so
i'm very aware yeah
i actually i bought a house like not
this time i at least went out and saw
this house the first house i ever owned
we did not see it first
wow my mother did that when my dad moved
the family from indiana to north georgia
and i i mean it's relevant and uh we
won't belabor this but as we're driving
from the airport
on that 40-minute drive about 35 minutes
in my mother looks at my dad and says
bill
what have you done
and i'm pretty sure she put the for sale
sign right back in the yard
[Laughter]
so
first off you know
and i and i apologize this is going to
get personal in the next you know a
little while here but
why did you make the move to get out of
um this version of the industry and into
a completely new one um
it really was complete
i don't call it serendipity uh i i
wasn't looking
um i i think you guys know me well
enough to know that i was happy i was
really happy i love doing what i did um
and i mean obviously i'm still
essentially kind of doing a lot of what
i did beforehand
um
and
i i felt like even with some of the
transition that we had from you know
coming out of the pandemic and then
being now like under c3 uh and reporting
in in that way
honestly there was a lot of opportunity
uh to continue to grow uh what you know
was kind of being put forth in front of
me uh in terms of that that those growth
opportunities were fantastic plus a much
larger team at our disposal that i
really hadn't had in the past so from a
standpoint of was i happy and was i
looking no i i wasn't looking for
anything i was i was happy doing i was
doing it obviously
floored that you know we didn't get to
execute bonnaroo that still i mean every
time it just
enters my brain i just start to just
cringe because that was so painful
um
but i i wasn't looking and then uh you
know honestly a headhunter uh reached
out to me and uh it's someone i'd known
um
as someone had known for a while and
he's like you know i know he knew i just
moved out to california where i you know
recently moved out to california for my
wife's position
and he was like listen i know you just
moved out here or recent and um but
there's this opportunity and i think you
would be perfect for it and i would be
remiss not to at least talk to you about
it can i uh let me can i jump in real
quick
should we do like station ids or like
that well something like that something
like that because i ran across run
traffic on the tens hang on a second i
ran across something that some sums all
this up and it's about it's almost a
better explanation of why we're talking
to you um
um
first of all i was thinking about it
this morning i think you had
maybe the best job next to mine that i
know of except you probably make a made
a whole lot more money than i do i love
what i do and and the job you had so i i
just did a search and the headline and
it's on global newswire and for people
who don't know who jeff is i think this
really just sort of but acclaimed music
festival director jeff cuellar joined
sixth man as vp of partnerships
uh which they describe as the global
leader in festivals at sea
now you we've always teased you about
your your titles that's a good one i
didn't even know what festivals that see
existed
but it points out you know your
leadership roles at ac c3 live nation
bonnaroo forecastle high water rail bird
moon river and a lot more
and i mean to me that's why
i mean you've been a guest on this show
a couple of times and brad and i've
always said you've been one of our
favorites because it's always been so
insightful but that's what we want to
talk about is
for 20 years since it started
i mean you've been right there
at the forefront of developing
these things that we love
so
i just thought it was interesting that
it's not just us that think that highly
of you it's all these other people well
let's just be fair i mean we know who
writes the press releases
[Laughter]
so however it gets done
i don't know what you're talking about
so it is an interesting time to do this
because uh well but i won't put words in
your mouth do you feel
some sort of shift in the festival world
away from
what you had built and the things that
you had seen in the the years with with
bonnaroo and the
then c3 live nation
uh i don't want to call it necessarily a
shift but i definitely see the growth in
our in the industry um you know we've
talked before in the past about how i
mean europe is i still feel
ahead of the united states when it comes
to the
uh adoption of the festivals and how
how consumers essentially you know is it
is woven into the fabric of you know of
of entertainment choices and things of
how how they want to consume and be a
part of these uh events and and the us
has been you know catching up quickly uh
in that space
um but one of the things that i think
has started to really develop over the
past few years is this immersive
experience and that is more i think as
artists have become
i don't say bigger but uh more developed
from a standpoint of not just being you
know banned on a stage but you know the
extensions of some make wine some make
whiskey some do you know podcasts some
have fashion lines some have there's so
much more that are entangled uh into
what is you know what it what it means
to be an artist now um that
these
more immersive
events
are really intriguing and and i think
that's kind of where
where they caught my attention
um when i started having the
conversations in my initial conversation
with anthony diaz who is the who's the
ceo of a six man
um was this
understanding that
they are gathering you know the goal is
to gather these passionate fan bases so
i mean a lot of people think you know
let's go grab the biggest artist there
is that you know is selling you know
millions upon millions of what are we
selling
even concert tickets uh these days um
and that's who you want to create a
destination experience around but it's
not it is really looking at those
artists that have these rabid fan bases
that are in reddit groups that have fan
clubs that are buying merch that are
that are doing all of the things that
that make you know that associated with
that that particular artist and then be
able to create an experience there
because
you ask a lot of a fan to come and to do
an immersive destination like come on
vacation you know with me and and and
understand what it is to be a part of it
but
you know
honestly it
while we've created and i'd say one of
the aspects that i i loved previously
about you know my other role was
i felt like i had a great opportunity to
find
and work in underserved markets
and and some of these you know that are
not the major metropolitan areas but you
know the charleston south carolina's the
louisville kentucky's the lexington
kentucky's um asheville north carolina
some of these hot spots that are just so
juicy in terms of what they offer as an
experience that
we got to shine a light on that yeah i
love when you say i love when you say
the words juicy hot spot
um
so i i loved that ability to create that
spotlight on some of those communities
and really dig in and be able to
showcase it through food through art
through all those different things
and the shift for this is
i'm now getting to do that with for an
artist and being able to look at it from
that standpoint and not necessarily just
partnering with an artist but it can be
doing maybe around a genre where are the
passions at you know uh you know before
i joined six man um you know they had
done like walker stalker cruise and
those people who are extremely
passionate about the walking dead got to
have that kind of experience over a
number of years um they've done comedy
before like in practical jokers they've
done all of these different things where
there is a passionate fan base and that
are looking for that
next level experience versus perhaps
going to let's call it a land-based
festival um that is
more or less
let's give you a smorgasbord i mean it's
curated someone would say a smorgasbord
but you know a curated experience down a
certain genre or whatever it may be but
you're still only getting what you know
45 minutes to maybe two hours if you're
a headliner on a stage so let me so let
me back up for a second so the there is
there is a basically what you're talking
about is um you can uh
you find an artist you find a a clan you
find a fan base you find the um the the
group of people that would join a cruise
um then you curate an entire experience
for them for insert amount of days the
bigger the artist i'm guessing the
bigger the cruise the smaller the artist
the more you know small the boat um am i
am i going in the right direction here
kind of uh you know i would say that the
model has been refined over the years in
terms of what makes sense and you know
norwegian about i guess it's about 10
years ago um
purchased six man so the ability to
have an understanding of where we can
move ships around
in order to create these experiences
norwegian owns two islands so therefore
our access to be able to create you know
do something different and actually
utilize the island as a potential
destination space and then resorts you
know resorts are part of this too um and
it does so it doesn't necessarily have
to involve a ship
but that is the i would say that the
bulk of the business
revolves around a ship uh but it doesn't
have to be so we you know we've done
events so all the best uh with john
prine um you know rest in peace uh that
that event that was done with them
melissa etheridge we've got one coming
up and we're doing uh that at play
mujeres um so
it doesn't have to be a cruise but it
can be but so
if there was just real quick if there
just happened to be
a rabid fan base that loved say a
podcast
and they all wanted to go
on a cruise together
um
that podcast probably wouldn't fill a
norwegian ship but would they have a
pontoon boat available for us
you know i it's podcast is actually one
of those verticals that you know we're
looking at is uh as an option i think
there is there's something there i mean
you look at the fans who are who are
tuning into podcast the way they are now
how does that work how do you super
serve that guest and maybe you know
either show them how the sausage is made
or do something interactive in a way
that really capitalizes on it but it's
it's so much more than just fans on a
stage right i mean that's what i was
gonna take tick-tock stars for instance
you get a whole bunch of tick-tock stars
on a
that's a it's a really
it's fascinating now that i've thought
about it because you're right i
immediately when all this happened i was
like oh jeff's
running some cruise ships um
but this makes so much more sense now
okay but it's the what i was going to
say listening to you and thinking back
to you know some of our conversations
about uh our moon river here which is a
boutique festival one of the things you
said was people are looking for that
next level experience they want a unique
experience they just don't want to go
stand in a field or
somewhere and watch a 90-minute set or a
45-minute set they want to feel like
they've seen something
uh unique
but it sounds like this takes it further
where it's a two-way street where not
just the fan is having that experience
but the artists now want to be involved
right it is
so my first
event that i did with six man was soul
shine uh or michael franti it was it was
a partnership with michael franti
and to see him i mean he's such an
amazing
individual period um but to see him
and his wife
on the ship
and their interaction
with guests you would think that they i
mean like it was christmas for them and
in terms of just some artists you know
they want maybe a little bit more
separation and we have the ability to
create that with different ways to
configure uh you know where they stay
there's a place called the haven that um
i mean honestly you talk about role like
a rock star looking like an amazing
place to to experience a show
be in the haven as an artist is like
wow i get paid to go do this um
and travel around through the caribbean
or wherever where we're gonna go europe
doesn't you know pick the destination um
so there are different even experiences
that we can provide to the artists but
those artists that choose to just kind
of
maybe be exposed a little bit and and
kind of let their guard down and say
these are my most passionate fans these
are the fans that will basically carry
me through as long as i choose to have a
career yeah they're kind of having that
understanding and knowing that
yeah i can go sit down and have a cup of
coffee and just allow people to come sit
down with me and we just trade some
stories and then i have to go walk away
because
now i am up to go do a set on a stage or
do um do a cooking presentation in terms
of like things that i like and just
being able to showcase
the personalities
that are a part of this artist and and
not just the host artist but even the
other artists that are trying to
gain those following so you've got a lot
of i mean it's not just one act you know
it's typically you know peppered with
several acts and those acts have the
opportunity to
make fans that will carry them through
the rest of their the wrestling yeah i
mean i mean
fans think it's
in the past especially it's you know
it's a glamorous life but they don't
understand it's 20 hours or 22 hours on
the same bus
roll into a city backstage unload play
the show and leave and you know rinse
and repeat
right you know which which has its
pluses um you know it beats digging a
ditch
but what you're talking about is uh you
know an immersive that's what i mean
it's both ways it is definitely both
ways right um and you know there's
definitely opportunity to make money you
know how much how much is this yeah how
much control are you giving the artist
in or whoever your feature is uh with
something like this i
ask because
when you start talking about the
immersive experience and changing and
growing sort of from what festivals were
it was remarkable to watch hootie and
the blowfish
basically just throw their own festival
uh we're gonna go to we're gonna go to
mexico uh we're gonna bare naked ladies
blues traveler and hootie and we're
gonna play for three days uh on the
beach um that was
it struck me as why aren't more bands
just doing that why aren't bands
curating their own their own things like
that and i wonder how much control if a
band really wants to how much control do
they have over what you're offering in
in one of these things
i think
i think it's becoming a model that more
and more bands
want to participate in the question is
not necessarily can they but they're
expensive you know i mean there
definitely is just like i mean anything
involving a live performance there is an
immense amount of risk that goes into it
so
where who is who is taking that risk on
and how you know how is that being you
know served so i i think there is you
know that hat you have to get past that
um and we kind of have created this
proprietary index of honestly we'll take
an artist and run it through to
determine whether or not we feel like
it's a safe bet and if it you know if it
gets high on the index it's something to
say like there's something here and if
the artist is going to have that kind of
participation and be a part of it we
feel like there's a great chance of
success there's also something you run
through you're like
you know that's that's going to be a
risk and if the artist is willing to
help sharing that risk then you know
perhaps you know we can take a look um
but it is it really is funny you know
kind of running through that stuff some
artists you would think are like slam
dunks and they are because
asking someone to join you on a three
four five seven night vacation um you
know and perhaps on a cruise ship
because let's be honest there's
stereotypes that are involved in cruise
ships and i think until people
experience one of these events they're
like oh my god that's totally not what i
thought was gonna be like i'll be honest
my first one too it was like i think i
went in with a certain expectations and
i was completely floored i'm like oh i
get it and you know one of the easiest
most tangible thing having my background
of the number of times i've used a porta
potty didn't have to use a porta potty
once like and that alone
but just like the ease of access and how
tired like you aren't like i'm a fan of
music festivals i'm going to continue to
go to them but you're exhausted and i
can honestly say even after working
you're like
it's not bad like that's that's a pretty
solid place to be in in the caribbean uh
you know enjoying it in kind of a
different way um you know everything's
got pluses minus but it's it's a it
really is a beautiful thing and to kind
of watch it and to see these fans and i
liken it to
um
the most passionate bonaroo fans so
think about that like on a scale of like
within a specific artist base it's just
the knowledge the understanding of the
operations the all of it like that's
where it kind of clicked with me when i
started having these interesting
conversations i'm like
we're basically taking the most
passionate fans which you know i dealt
with on a boundary level and
doing it in a destination what's been
the most interesting one that you've
done so far
uh i'm still i'm still uh i'm not i'm
not salty yet uh i've now only had my
second uh cruise
um
so my first wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait is there a group of the
salty is there there's like an induction
ceremony to become salty is there a
whole thing really yeah yeah you start
getting like there's number of events
and there's number of days at sea
and it's it's pretty amazing to see the
you know some of
my colleagues and stuff the number of
days they've been at see a number of
events they've participated in you get
to a certain number and all of a sudden
you're wearing an eye patch you're like
yeah you go around the cape and you got
to get an earring is that yeah is it all
that you just you understand things
about maritime law and other stuff that
uh is just it's just a different
it's just a different life so you've
done you've done two so far then i've
done two yep i did uh joe bonamas our
partnership with joe bonamassa the
keeping the blues alive um which i think
was either the sixth or the seventh uh
iteration of uh of that event in fact
we've got him again here in uh in europe
so we're gonna mediterranean one will be
sailing this summer um
but uh yeah and two from seoul shine
with franti to joe bottoms to keep the
blues alive completely different
experiences hands down and
but the one thing that carries true is
the passion and just
the sheer happiness
everyone is just billowing out the
entire
time and um it really is a way to focus
in on you know with our company and our
values is you know super serve the guest
and i think the the artists see that too
as a way of saying like you are taking
care of again the people who are going
to take care of us
for the rest of my career does this feel
like
next level um or an addition or does it
feel like it's going to replace
something will it replace festivals or
live shows or just feels like it's a
next level it is
it definitely is a next level type of
thing it is it is not for you know not
for every but i think
as artists recognize their power and of
course their ability to to make money um
on the touring side of things
it is
to me it's almost one of the purest ways
for them to build that bond with their
fan base i mean 311 i want to say we've
done 10 cruises with them uh 10 events
with them and now we are we're helping
to handle 311 day as a part of their
team that was actually just in vegas we
had team just get back from uh the 311
day in vegas um but to think that you
know we've been doing their cruises for
a number of years and then you know now
helping them on in when they do 311 days
so it's like every other year is when
they do their cruise but i mean it's
thinking about 311. i mean the you know
no one can say that they're
huge in terms of like chart popping and
things of all those lines but they've
got that fan base that you know will
carry them the rest of the way and
they're they're passionate our our
fastest sound before we did launched the
emo's not dead so we partnered with uh
matt cupchal and the emos not dead
social handle and launched that event
that's happening this uh
this fall
um cohedon cambria
was the fastest selling event in six men
history i want to say it sold out in
like three days
and now you've got uh emo's not dead
which i think sold out in two but you
think about like coheed and cambrie like
no offense to cody cameron the
phenomenal act but you know they're not
a household name for a lot of folks
and they've got a
massively passionate fan base just
sitting here thinking our own roger
allen wade who people will know he's
johnny knoxville's cousin if you're
going to be dumb you got to be tough
you know he's a known guy he's a
chattanooga guy he just this past week
came off of a cruise with lucinda
williams and emmylou harris and
somebody else and my point in that is
emmy lou and lucinda are not people that
i imagine say you know what i want to
hang out on a boat with people i don't
know
but they did oh yeah multiple times they
they are they are pretty salty
themselves um and i think understand the
uh the uh the value that you know these
types of events bring to the table yeah
they just got off the the outlaw
cruise so it's outlaw country cruise
that's it which we are having the first
or first or second iteration of outlaw
west this fall and i think they already
announced dates for for outlaw the
continuation of it because it's now
hitting its so so the so these all
obviously poured from different cities
um
when you get
the people that buy tickets the people
who are are
are they mostly local from the city that
they're porting from
all over are they so when you said the
mediterranean uh that's happening uh you
know
am i am i buying something that is
including a flight to get to the port
city um or
fights on you okay so at least in the
port city you it's up to you to get to
the port city um and then from there
you know where you're you're essentially
your ticket your cabin pays for your all
of your experience uh on the ship you're
obviously your your stay and food now
there are some like uh upper food
packages that you can get there are some
restaurants and stuff that are on board
ship that you can pay a little extra for
something along those lines and then
your drinks are
are on you as well i i hate that i just
asked that question because it turned
you into a travel agent all of a sudden
you don't know what i get for my package
it's new the number of new people who
get introduced to cruising because of
this
is i mean let's let's be let's be frank
it's why norwegian you know was so
impressed with it and wanted to you know
wanted to bring six men in the fold is
it is a way to help shape or shake the
stigma that cruising is just for um
older demographic because you know we
gotta we gotta paramore crews you know
we've done paramore for a number of
years you talk about you know the you
know it's a young demographic well i
guess at least it was younger even when
we started doing these things um but
that are piling on and you hear the
majority of them this is their first
time on a ship and it's definitely not
going to be their last now are they
you know i think it's it's it's up to us
to continue to deliver and over deliver
on those experiences whether it's
changing ports acts that support it the
experiences that are on board um
all of it but you know it all goes as
part of the experience that's what i was
gonna say i could see where you know my
first one maybe i went to the caribbean
with coheed and then i find out they're
gonna next time do an alaska one
i could see where you know
i get to see the band i love but now i'm
gonna you know do a cruise in a part of
the world i've never seen before so
exactly so so this is all this is all
with uh six man um is it is it in
conjunction with any of the live nation
aeg's of the world are you guys all
booking this yourself
uh it's primarily coming to us but but
yes and we have worked with uh you know
other partners in terms of of trying to
you know secure talent and things along
those lines but you know again it's it's
one of those things that you got to kind
of get it and you know we try to invite
you know folks to see it and to see you
know the haven especially and there's
different class ships i mean to your
point beforehand like what size ship
we've got a model that works around uh
like what called the jewel class like
the norwegian pearl is a is a ship that
we use quite often but we've configured
it to a point like we know how to
load and unload in terms of production
build a stage on the pool deck and the
types of things that make it work um
in a flawless type of way because one
thing that's different is you know when
we build festivals depending upon the
event you know i'd get anywhere from
nine you know
three four five nine days to build an
event you've got less you've got hours
because that ship
could potentially be somewhere else it's
coming into dock we basically crane
stuff on
decorate it out you know vibe it out the
way he's vibed out load up passengers
and and we're going and then the way we
kind of have some certain things
structured we'll do kind of back to
backs so you could have
kiss coming off
and soul shine coming on in the same day
and we're able to flip
branding everything with the ship and
having
how many a year are they pulling off
um
next year
we are i think right now we're going to
be we're slated for 22 events
okay so but we've got we've got right
now i've got three back-to-back that are
about to leave
um i deported out of miami um and then
we'll have i think five more in the fall
uh and then one one in europe or one in
the mediterranean this summer and this
is you know obviously it's kind of our
as we're kind of scaling back up to
to get to take place but yeah 2023 is
going to be an exciting year and 2024 is
going to be even bigger and we're we're
already
you know 2023 is just about fully booked
um and then 2024 is i would say
you know
do you have do you have like a white
whale do you have a big one that you
that you're just holding in the back
your pocket like uh i got a i got i got
lady gaga i'm really
um i think that's part of the mentality
that's probably shifted for me because
you know i used to think about
headliners and you know what is going to
be best to draw in a festival crowd and
pull them into whatever city we're doing
um where my
has changed a lot is
who are the most passionate fan bases so
i don't really think about it in terms
of like white whales anymore and from
that standpoint of like who do we want
to see on you know what stage of
bonnaroo it is more or less now who can
we you know who's the best for us to
super serve like who who are who ha who
gets it and who um
you know who's got that fan base that
just is really attractive to create
something special and then we build our
own event so like chaomo which is about
to happen uh this iteration of it is a
festival brand that we've created um
that you know we take and and move a lot
of places um
what's i'm trying to think of of more
uh
that we've got there's there's just so
many um we've got a new one that's about
to launch here in
like
two weeks three weeks so i gotta look at
my calendar somewhere um that uh
there'll be a brand new festival concept
we've got coming out that i'm
personally i'm really really excited
about it's uh
well
well speaking of festivals
yeah um
what
do you miss the most about
the festival world and the festival life
oh that's a good question i i mean i
would probably say my team
um the team that that we've built you
know over the years and and when i say
team you know it's the you know the
immediate you know colleagues the same
company stuff but as well as the
the industry as a whole from that
standpoint and getting into it in a city
and trying to solve
those kind of challenges like it is a
it's a special group of people and you
know they are family uh in a lot of ways
and they will continue to be family i i
will always support um everything
they're currently doing out there so it
is i i would say you know the fact that
you know some of the some of these
people i've been working with for 20
years um i'm not
working with some of them and you know
but there are some that you know have
jumped over uh and and are now working
with us
in different ways i mean i've got i've
got a couple people that were that
worked with me you know ac
uh on our events that are now full-time
at six man so it is
that i know that will develop and i know
you know that will happen there's also
several that are contractors that are
part of six-man events that i've seen
them like
oh my god yeah we've worked together a
bunch so i think that will start to
co-mingle more um but it really is the
team and i'll say to the cities you know
there is there is something special
about
uh i mean i i'll i'll say it
no matter what you know manchester
coffee county has has been a home for me
i think when i added up days i've spent
more time in uh in manchester than any
other city in my life
um so you know those types of of things
i still keep in touch with a lot of
people uh in those places and even other
cities that you know that we we've done
business in and uh that that you know i
i liked being able to shine a light on
those communities because they are so
special i want to
i want to ask about manchester in the 20
years and all that but let's work
backwards a little bit if we can
you mentioned it
um
and we've obviously talked about it
probably to death on this show and a lot
of other people have
but if you don't mind what was september
like um
i mean
just leading up to it and everything i
mean obviously 2020 canceled 2020 moved
from june to september
you know
i i don't think i had been more excited
to go into a run
and you know it was railbird into
bonnaroo than in the moon river
and to go into that run i i don't think
i had ever been so excited and i knew we
were
there were a lot of challenges that we
were going to be facing for all of our
events
i mean just coming out of you know the
pandemic and what we did and how do you
you know everything was changing and you
could feel fan frustration because you
know we're having you know we're giving
real-time information on stuff and uh is
for some people they you know liked what
we were saying some people didn't um i
mean i think that you know it kind of
goes without that political environment
um
but
going in uh i i had that zest of
i was so ready so ready uh to to do a
lot and just being at home i think i
think even my wife and family were like
you've been home too long like you gotta
go right um and so the
jones and just to get out there and be
on site and and feel it um i think one
way i physically did it as i went out to
uh the farm first
did some work out there then went to
lexington to do rail but then came back
of course the farm and then and then up
to
um chattanooga um
so
you know even even coming after you know
it was the biggest rail bird you know we
ever did there and it was it was a great
event we had some we had some stumbles
that you know they needed so how
corrected so back to back to september
for a second how
close
was it to being a guest
do you do how close do you think that it
actually could have been
i think a lot closer than
people realize we built it it was built
it was it was ready to go um the
challenge was for for those of us that
uh you know saw manchester salty uh and
bonnaroo salty
we knew 04
and knowing the amount of rain that we
had in o4 yeah exactly
i was knowing the amount of rain we had
no for and and understanding what that
did to the property and what that did to
the experience what that did
all over the place
it was going to be worse
i think you just hit a point point that
i totally forgot about explain what it
did to the property because i had to pay
a kid fifty dollars to pull me out of a
a mud pit um and this was just a random
kid from the neighborhood
yeah and i think jeff you're gonna
you're gonna say it but i know we talked
about it i talked about it is people
don't understand
they see a mud puddle and they think
it's just a mud puddle they don't
understand what 80 000 people walking
through that mud puddle
does to it over a day or two right but
but yeah
that's a great question what i mean what
were you thinking
um
the what we lovingly call the back 60
and seeing how we had changed some
things up operationally and even if we
wouldn't have changed up things
operationally that you know that that
honestly that didn't matter there was
there was so much rain i mean i don't
i'd have to go back and look at you know
tennessee records but i think during
that span i think that had to have been
like the wettest time frame like on
record period it was just an immense
amount of rain and what would happen the
ground was so soft you put any weight
and when i say anyway i'm talking like a
human foot
you've just now created a mess
and
the
could we have gotten everybody in
m maybe but the amount of disruption mud
just
everything one who would have destroyed
the grounds two
everyone would have been stuck and there
no one would have been getting out of it
and it would have been
it would have been a safety issue and i
think that's the other talk about talk
about some bad headlines afterwards oh
it would have been i mean like i mean
heck we talked about everything i
referenced tomorrow world uh beforehand
we all know what happened there i think
it would i actually don't think i know
it would have been worse than that and
it it's not at a fault it's mother
nature you know she
she she won in that level so
when when people think you know like you
asked me like how close we got
the
amount of brain power that went into
every possible thing from opening up
refund windows to shifting things around
do we you know not open a day and open
up a day later in order to like let the
sun come in
i would say every single plausible and
even non-plausible option was put on the
table some executed and done to give us
a shot because
no one no one no one on that team even
the people who were slogging it out like
actually getting you know just
dirty muddy gross
um wanted to
bring it down when you make a call when
you make a call like that how many
people are in the room
batting ideas around
uh i mean you know you bring in the
brain trust you know it's a small group
but it's you know you you bring in the
people who specialize and know certain
things because as you know it's like a
ripple effect everything is affected so
like how does this impact food vendors
can they get shipments or you know can
they get their shipments in to get stuff
done can we service porta-potties can we
all those different operational pieces
um factor into it and so
you solve one problem but you have to
make sure you didn't just create three
more and so it's a small team
but you got the best in the business in
terms of trying to figure it out and and
share that collective knowledge of
what happens to the property when it
gets wet and then what is needed to be
serviced to make things
you know
take place did anybody in the brain
trust disagree
no okay totally unanimous billionaires i
i think we there were some that you know
wanted to try and push it but
it's
it's a safety issue i mean it comes down
you just can't you can't you can't do
that anymore like i don't think you can
take those types of risks anymore it's
not worth it to do it from a standpoint
of of
destroying the brand and and what has
been built over 20 years so you know
could you ramrodded it in there maybe
but then then you're potentially killing
it for the next 20 years and is that
worth it and again i go back to just
safety and experience and if everyone
has a crap experience like it's just
your way that it's just it's just not
not worth it i think that's where that
salty thing comes i mean that's a
you were there in 2004
brad and i were in fork and louisville
you know with when the
gust nado or whatever the heck that was
came off the river and you know i
remember you running down the
running towards the stage get everybody
out of here yep uh i'll never i'll never
forget sam smith poor sam smith comes
out he says hello louisville and then
three seconds later good night louis
run
so i mean you've seen all those kinds of
things yeah it's it's fun i you know
being you know in my limited time right
now in this position to see the salty
folks and making some of the decisions
uh and it's kind of interesting too like
with the caribbean and able to work
one of the benefits is one we've got
indoors as well as you know doing an
outdoor pool deck but knowing that so
many things are so close some of the
hops that you do are port stops
you could really do in like a couple of
hours so they're just out doing donuts
in the you know in the ocean like
tooling around but what it does is it
allows you to have time so they can see
store fronts and stuff coming through
and like go around things and so from
that fan experience out of stuff there's
more control and being able to watch
some of this stuff firsthand and learn
you know how uh you know how my
colleagues and stuff like that navigate
that um is is fascinating to watch
because it really is like it's it's just
a completely different beast and
some things you have control over some
things of course you don't let me ask
along those lines then because on our
last show we had gotten an email from
bonnaroo about the changes that have
been made paving some of the roads
some changes to the what do they call it
storm water and that sort of thing so
you haven't been gone that long i assume
you probably have a pretty good idea um
we haven't been on the farm in three
years um
what sort of things changes
uh do you know of or do you think have
happened along those lines i mean
you guys have been very good
and and we laugh about it you know i've
written about it
you plant grass nobody you know cares
about planting grass except for bonnaroo
people or shade and those sorts of
things
so
you know for the veterans what sort of
things do you think have happened to the
farm up there
um you know i haven't seen the you know
i know there was probably more stuff
that's been done since uh since
september um in regards to improvements
um
so i'd be kind of curious to see certain
things but a lot of things like people
never got to see
are you know like well i guess people
wouldn't see production road but
production road being paved i mean stop
it that's the paved road that's that is
the fact that glory hallelujah jesus
praise yeah your name god
i uh
it is uh it is glorious like so when i
was down there um like i would do i
would do kind of runs like i found like
a good three-mile loop that i would do
uh just to go for a run and get some
exercise in and yeah there's a good part
of the game running
but when they were talking about the
pedro just just to make sure when they
talk about the paved roads they're not
talking about a paved road through
cineroo they're you're talking about the
paved roads around
in production road and down to like the
campsites right correct yeah okay
yeah see i was worried
me and barry argued about this last week
but
you just don't pave a road through
cinero you just don't do that your feet
have to touch the ground and it cannot
be through asphalt yeah but you want to
be able to service things where you have
your heavy equipment and things like
that that uh that do differently and
there's always been work done regarding
like drainage and like how do you how do
you you know map certain things out to
get water so that you know things can
drain and then the ground can rehab
quickly uh where certain things are
positioned there was a lot of thought i
think you know take the benefit of that
amount of rain is
you know for some of that group uh you
know they're new or they're newer to the
property so they got to see
the worst you know i mean what 04 to
2021 like look at that span of years
that we had never experienced something
like that ever again so there is now
another you know
there's now a new brain trust that has
that has now seen what weather can do
and therefore impact some of the
decision making because you know we
didn't own the property 04. so the
ability to make certain changes couldn't
be happened but now that you know that
team or you know the the more the recent
team can got to see a lot of that
i think you know
it makes it easier case to say why you
should do something when you're like
yeah
you can make it happen
to be to be clear
04 was one of the worst experiences i've
ever been a part of i literally said i
will never come back to this place i
loathed it the literally the next year
the the girlfriend then
eventually wife the girlfriend of the
time looked at me and she said why are
we not going to bonnaroo it looks
incredible i said i will never
ever go back to that hell hole again
because that's what to your point it was
so bad the user experience was so bad
and if i will always give bonnaroo
credit for it's a lot like apple apple
understands
user experience and user interface and
that is the most important part of their
entire um operation and and bonnaroo
just has always done that and excelled
at that so
you know it must have been a very
difficult decision in september but a
worthwhile one with that being said
how
this is what you do for a living
what is the
most important thing
when
you're trying to communicate
even basic information hard to deal with
information with a brand voice how what
what are you trying to do
there i think it's authenticity
you know it is it is being you know heck
it's one of the you know the the
things that stay true to rue and and i
and i think that honestly extends into
everything so every event everything
that you know i i i have my hands in
i think of what that what it what it
means for that specific event and what
do they need to hear
um that makes it better the the
challenge is
so many people want to believe they're
experts and think they've got the
information that can
counter counterbalance
the truth
and you know if someone comes in and
says you know i've been to 17 bonnaroo's
or something like that it's like yeah
but you're a fan like you you aren't in
the back room making decisions
um and that you know again again that
goes across the board is
people try to say you know i i've
watched message boards and things like
that for for a lot of events just spiral
down it's like well i know and it's like
actually you don't and then
do you jump in like as as an expert like
do you say like you're 100 wrong and i
know because i signed a check on that
one like that's not what happened um or
do you just
let it happen and that that probably is
i think that's some of the stuff that's
changed over the years of how engaged
message boards or you know comment
sections whatever have you engaged on a
reddit or a message board have you done
it
uh every time i do i regret it
um i have and it mostly is a lot of
times it's like let it play out and your
people that are grounded in reality
uh will typically come
come to defense and help squash it
sometimes you utilize there are other
methods in terms of going to
influencers or taste makers to provide
them the correct information and allow
that voice to because
i i think at times you know if i go in
there and say something
i'm paid to be there and say something
like even even if i've got the right
information correct information i can
you know give you the full timeline of
wherever it may be
you may not listen to me she's like oh
he's just towing a company line or you
know he's just all about profit nah
um that you know that comes out of that
so do you do you have a conversation
with someone that you know that there's
that trust and they can be a taste maker
to say like hey hear the facts you know
do what you want with them here they are
uh and and allow and allow that to kind
of happen but it is it's that
authenticity it is
it's a challenge i mean it really is you
know that some of the things i think
that probably get me more and i know uh
you guys as a stand-up amazing uh
journalists and members of the media
you're actually gonna i tell fart jokes
on the radio i am no journalist yeah but
you're gonna fact check you're not just
gonna throw something out there and say
and say that you know this is it because
you know bob down the street told me so
you're gonna dig in you're gonna ask for
comments you're gonna find out where
things come from and i you know i i
never i never wanna say anything bad
about the press but
today in these times there are more of
just
stuff getting out that is just
blatantly not true it's like
did you even ask the question because if
you would have if you would have just
texted me i would have been like
no that's wrong do i have a comment no
but i can tell you that that's wrong
like that is factually inaccurate um and
that's that's frustrating as well it's
because when you're combating that stuff
again you're not going to win i'll say
the thing
about bonnaroo and and um you've been a
huge part of it and i'm not saying that
because you're you're sitting right here
uh
it you guys have always seemed to
approach it that we're not just worried
about this year we're worried about next
year and the next and the next and that
that's a different attitude
than a lot of people you know have and
it makes a huge difference
like grass like bathrooms like water
runoff you know we all laugh about that
every year i write it but i'm like
that's long-term thinking
uh and
brad brad said it with the last time we
were there when we walked in at night
and saw the lights in the trees you know
we just went crazy about that kind of
thing but that's that little detail
that you know
for the first timers would have not
realized it was new
but for veterans is like oh that's a
really cool improvement well i mean look
it's those little details that as a guy
that you know runs a radio brand which
is definitely not a music festival it's
those little details that when i watch
other radio stations do drive me nuts
absolutely drive me nuts i'll give you
an example literally over my two
shoulders um
jeff probably has an example like this
in the bottom room farm but this was the
logo that was done before me that's the
logo i did there that tight face drives
me bat [ __ ] crazy because it's
completely inconsistent it's crooked it
drives me nuts people do this all the
time and when i see somebody pay
attention to details like bonnaroo right
um
by the way i fixed it with the new logo
just mind okay
but
uh when i see bob the other one is still
there well that's because it's yeah what
are you gonna do i can't i can't solve
every stupid problem
but um the uh but when bonnaroo gets the
little details right like that it makes
me feel really happy because i've
invested all of this time and energy
into a brand that cares and and that
knows that the details matter to the
point that i was trying to sort of
insinuate
with the um with the question
it does feel as though the brand's
communication has been
troublesome at best spotty at best and
i wonder if
there are you know advice being given um
if they are aware of stuff like that if
it is in the consciousness or are they
just trying to hold on and survive and
just make it work for right now
obviously i'm not in that room anymore
and i can't necessarily speak to that
but that's why i freely ask you because
now you're running i can say that i you
know the people that i left that are
that are still there is just slogging it
out and putting it to is still some of
the most passionate people in the
business and there's a lot fewer of them
right
no there's there's more than i mean you
know that have had you know 20 years no
yeah there's
very few uh that have lasted long but i
mean there's still
i would say a lot of people are still
within it are still you know veterans of
the business you know that are
from that standpoint understand what it
takes to pull off a large scale event
every event being different but the
group that is behind it and the group
that is still pushing forward on it um
some of the most passionate they care
they genuinely care and want to do
what's right and that comes from the top
down and the bottom up i mean it's it's
it's a whole
everybody i think they understand and
respect the power you know that they
they yield or wheeled within
um that brand specifically and there's a
lot of care and attention done to it um
you know i think we're all navigating
you know coming out of the pandemic
especially as we rank back up in the
live event world you know
the
pressure and the desire to
go go go and and do more and and some of
that
can make you tired
you know we're all human we all make
mistakes uh and that's gonna happen um
but i you know again not in those rooms
but i do know
a lot of the people who are still there
obviously and i can't say enough
positive things about the group that is
there that is making the decisions that
is you know doing everything they can to
to make that event and to make every
event they're a part of special and it's
it is a
it's a family within the industry that
you know i think for those that are
salty and have been in it for quite some
time
that carrying attention is there because
you don't do an event
as a one-off like that is when you go in
doing something the the intent is to
create a legacy on it and to build a
brand and to build a a passionate
property that um that will that will
stand the test of time and you know
sometimes things come and go and that's
just the natural evolution of things but
that is definitely the goal going in uh
and that's you know i can speak that
even now as we're looking at destination
stuff as we approach our our partners uh
in terms of artists or or not even ours
but like how we want to do things
it's not about one event like we're
already thinking this is how it's going
to evolve over the next five years and
if we're not
in that same if we're not together some
pats go in that place then we need to
have a conversation if this is gonna be
the right thing to go because you have
to build these things future you have to
take those right steps in order to make
it um to maintain longevity so so as
somebody i absolutely absolute trust um
would you consider and understanding
that you are
sort of biased because these are very
close friends and people that you care
about and and think that are doing uh
you know wonderful work and i don't deny
any of that
just
be totally honest and real with me
you feel as though even though there's
been a lot of change it has really
adjusted the whole structure has
almost been completely upended
you totally feel confident that it is
going to be the same feeling
walking in there this year than it was
five years ago four years ago three
years ago
i do
and and where i go with that is it's
still incumbent upon the fans
i think the delivery of and and fan
mentality and and how people come
together is different i mean let's be
honest none of us
here we're not young anymore um you know
this is this stuff's not meant for us
a lot of these things
a lot of these events across the board
are built for you know for the youth in
a lot of ways um so
that is the one thing that i did
you can't look through that lens because
what was important to you and i five
years ago it's probably not the same
thing that's important to us now so
that is going to change the musical
tastes are going to change so
it would be remi you know it would be
wrong to kind of look through the lens
like five years ago because
it is it is a constant torch passing for
an event if it's going to maintain it if
it's going to stay like one thing the
entire time it's never going to stand
the test of time because
things change like you get married
you've got kids you've got life
responsibilities and i can't go do this
or i'll come back to it and you have to
understand there are certain pieces that
will that will maintain that are still a
part of that soul but it's not for i
don't wanna say it's
it's not targeted to you anymore and as
long as you're willing to understand
that yeah there's going to be kids there
but you know five years ago 10 years ago
you were a kid too
um you know from that standpoint so
that's the part that i think has changed
but from from from that aspect
i do think it will maintain but it it's
not just incumbent upon the producers it
is the fans maintaining that spirit and
that understanding of what this event is
or what any event is for that matter um
and keeping it going because the fans
choose they don't want to
then you know that's kind of when you
make that decision of do you keep doing
the event or not can you in any way sort
of quantify or qualify
how that 20-year run has gone i mean
from what you maybe envisioned it in uh
2002 to
to where it is has it been a
a straight line has it been
you know were there moments where you
where
because there was for me and i i know
when it started it had this hippie jam
fest
label
and it took a lot of hits early on when
people said it's lost its soul it's
changed but having talked to you
and ashley that was always sort of the
plan was
you know you you brought that group in
first because they would camp
and the idea was to add vip and nicer
you know all the things that that you've
added but you can't do that all at once
monetarily you didn't own the farm so
that's what i mean by
i mean is is there um
a piece of paper somewhere in somebody's
desk that says here's where we want to
be in 2022
and how close did you get i guess is
what i'm asking
oh god that's a great question i think
for the first several it was just like
we just hope we get to do it again uh
type of thing and you know i don't i
wouldn't say there was
a long-term vision goal at that point
time i think it was just a matter of if
we could make it five years that's
awesome
um and i think probably starting around
maybe 0-405 it was like
oh [ __ ] they're still coming like we've
really got something here making it past
04 you're just like oh all right i came
back you know fast yeah they came back i
think really that long-term planning
started to become more evident once the
farm was purchased okay um and i think
that's where it's gone so you know has
it
every year you're always kind of taking
taking bits and chunks
off and and you know there are
definitely plans that you're going after
and sometimes you know when when you've
got a good one you know it allows you to
do you know take more of those chunks
off other times you you can't um
so
i i would say
yes i think
you know we did get there now was it
maybe that path that we all thought were
going to go down
no uh yeah and there's definitely peaks
and valleys in that um and i think
we've taken we've always swung and i
would say that is we've always tried and
no one can accuse us or accuse you know
the groups over the years for not going
for it and and swinging and trying new
things some things landed awesome and
other things fell completely flat and
that fan base was the quickest to call
you i'd be like
you uh you definitely um missed the mark
on that one would you would you call
would you call missing the mark a big
square that you walked into
[Laughter]
i don't know what you're talking about
brad okay got it
yeah somebody walked through i mean i
think i know what you're talking about
uh roll like a rock star
didn't work you guys took that up you
know you
change it and right i mean i think you
said that three or four years ago and
yeah you find out what works right i
mean and again things change it's like
yeah the program was fantastic but when
you own something is there a way to do
it better and uh you know some of the
some of the the newer faces that have
come in and and i'll call them out by
name tuba um
is
some of his approach in terms of asking
why
and uh has reframed a lot of what you
know even the way i approach certain
things sometimes is has been fantastic
you know i think it gave a real
uh like injection of of looking at how
we do things instead of saying like
that's the way we've always done it it's
like why
is there a better way to do it yeah like
let's look at a better way let's do the
best way we can do it not that's the way
we've always done it now we always know
is the best way to do it because we
learned that that's the only way that's
going to work that's one thing but
question it and and figure things out
and that group has i think has always
been great about at really questioning
what works what doesn't and again you
got to fail to succeed in a lot of ways
and so uh i think there's this this
piece happens it happens across the
board well so it's sort of to be sort of
to barry's question what was something
that you never ever got to finish or do
that was on the list that you said oh
man if we could do blank
and you never got it
um
this is gonna sound you know you talk
about grass and things being the thing
sewer
oh a sewer
toilets are a good being able to to
handle and address the uh wastewater
issue
i think that's one of those things that
that to me is that's one that i really
you know i put a lot of time and energy
on personally uh that i wanted to see a
solution out of that because i think
that could have been
a game changer in terms of uh how and
you know that's gonna be something
that's you know that's gonna be that you
talk about white whales that's the one
that is
so many times it's been it's been within
grasp and uh
you gotta make those decisions but yeah
that one i think is a is a big one and
you start you know and i would say other
pieces you know specifically for the
farm is
really thinking about that investment of
how we get or how they now we not we
anymore uh how uh
traffic being addressed and being able
to because you start looking at the pain
points and i think that was a kind of a
shift in focus even the last couple
years of theirs like what are the
biggest pain points
and what can we do what kind of time and
energy can we put towards addressing it
one of the things i think that shifted a
big way is uh guest services and looking
at um how do we take care of the fame or
how how you know how are the fans taken
care of so like from wayfinding to like
those types of things again it's grass
you know it's not putting you know
rolling stones in the main stage or
something along those lines it's it's
those little things that truly make the
experience better and special um and i
say that's that's part of what's really
exciting about you know what i do what
i'm doing now in six minutes the scale
is just different i don't have to think
about
120 000 people uh on a farm you know
with staff artists everything else i get
to think about a ship that's contained
and what are these microcosms of
experience and knowing that really one
one piece of signage can make a
difference in a lot of different ways
and having my mindset come in because
i'm you know i i feel blessed and lucky
to have the experience that i had and
now get to take that into this new phase
and
you know
challenge ask a lot of those why
questions for those some of us who have
been salty and to say like well let's
look at it this way see if it
if it changes the guest experience in in
a positive way and that you talk about
maybe what gets me up in the morning
right now and gets me really excited and
keeps me up at night are the
opportunities right now that that are
there to
really
think differently about how we create
these immersive experiences and
understand
i get to try things in a different way
you know the the
economies of scale are completely
different jeff
your answer your answer is exactly why
this show exists i mean nothing makes me
more excited than your answer being
sewage
and i'm totally honest about that
because the moment that me and barry
were walking backstage and i noticed
the the fact that the the core the the
lines were in pvc pipes
and
i said how many
hundreds of yards of pvc do they have
here and to think that that somebody put
it together to put it over to the side
so that people weren't tripping over it
that's when the show started yeah that's
when we started i started looking at the
whole thing differently i started
looking at what you do now it a little a
little bit differently how do these
things start getting put together and
the answer being sewage is just another
line of
uh you know us
well i may be like one of the very few
people who are thinking that uh by the
way uh but yeah those are the those are
the things that i know
that's the thing you've you've stressed
i think since we've been talking
since i've known you is
it's not just the act on the stage it
starts with the ticket experience you
know did i have a hassle buying my
ticket because if i did i already got a
bad taste in my mouth
you know
did my ticket show up on time did i have
a problem did i did i get to my campsite
on time you know or in a in a reasonable
amount those are the things
when you leave
that you remember
you know the the um
the great show helps and it will
overcome
huge in some cases but if you left there
and it's like man
i didn't have any problem with bathrooms
that's a good day yeah
yeah yeah i mean
it is i got in and out with no traffic
it is it is pretty remarkable you know
what
i got to see the rolling stones of
bonnaroo unfortunately i [ __ ] myself
um
i just
because because the porta potty was full
yeah
what are you going to remember when you
go home
how's the show don't remember oh yeah
that's another problem
man jeff i again we say this to you
every time and it's not just blowing
smoke up your ass i didn't know you the
minute that you came on the show years
ago and fell in love with you because
you are exactly the way that you speak
as a brand you're authentic um you are
uh incredibly gifted at what you do and
you're
first and foremost you're really
generous so being as generous as you are
with your time it's it's as appreciated
as you can ever imagine so thank you so
much for uh hanging out with us and
walking us through the new property the
the former property
uh and i hope the move goes well thank
you when you guys uh invites on the
table come join us
[Music]
jump on the ship
hey i'm ready i'm ready you name the
time the place
i mean we can start sussing out this uh
this pod this podcast concept i love it
i love it yeah yeah the the less work i
have to do the better uh
barry will testify i uh well it is it is
work uh but you just could be in it for
the best destination yeah i'm in i'm in
if i get to hang out with youtube guys
shirtless
you can't do that
tropical destination and barry porter
that is uh
sore ice i love it
yeah thank you you let us know we're
there excellent thanks jeff see you soon
[Music]
consequence podcast network